okay it's uh time to find out what's
going on with the young people in
America oh is that why I'm here yeah
yeah that's why you're here get ready
for a youth Quake
I want to find out because listen this
summer has it's been all about uh Taylor
Swift or as I call her T Swift or TS or
sometimes T.S Eliot because that's odd
she's been so successful she's left a
wasteland behind her
um kids you gotta learn something my
point is that I brought in the biggest
Taylor Swift fan I know and uh he's
David hopping he's my real assistant now
that son has just become a professional
goofball 24 7. oh okay well come on he
really I mean you still are you are a
professional goofball 24 7. wouldn't you
say that okay sure I guess yeah I guess
you are so you are yes why do I do what
you do when you're like I guess when
when you say something it was a really
good Nicholas Cage that's fantastic
anyway let's get let's stick to the
point yeah it's not you let me tell you
something oh David hopping's here and
David hopping uh you actually went
you're the only one in this room that
went to the Taylor Swift uh concert I
did and everyone's talking about it
um so this is you know I don't think
anyone else who's seen the Taylor Swift
shows this summer has actually been
recorded giving their thoughts on it so
this is a real scoop yeah and he's been
multiple
how many times have you gone twice okay
three times a thousand dollars yeah how
much was just you you don't let the
system work you you have to work the
system
David what means he came in through the
codes it means he came in through the
air conditioning duct
a lot of people were saying I love the
part of the concert where that that
white Midwestern guy falls through the
ceiling
and hits the floor really hard uh so
tell me what was was it amazing it's
it's a seven hour concert is that right
she does like three and a half hours
just herself and her opening act is they
show Dr Zhivago which is a three-hour
movie I was out until you said that yeah
and then by your end yeah right they
showed Dr Zhivago then they build an
Aztec Temple uh in real time and then
she comes out so the whole thing you're
18 hours in okay so uh how was it the
best night best night of your life yeah
really wait you've had dinner at my
house oh I have
statement
yeah okay I had burritos you love
burritos
anyway
um so it was incredible yes everyone
says she gives a fantastic about how she
does it I was exhausted I felt like I
was hungover the next day I had had no
alcohol okay is it possible that there's
more than one that she has other people
come out well first of all she's she's
performing in a huge space and there are
a bunch of times where she says before
my next song I'll be right back and she
ducks behind right something like that
kind of switch yeah and it's possible
that they pull the old thank you Texas
switch and she comes out and it's an
easy look to replicate is that possible
if there are nine people backstage I
don't think so okay oh those Camp their
their cameras are getting and like her
face is just on the but what if that's
pre-recorded video pre-recorded video
there's a stand-in live because no one's
close enough you know except for people
that pay like thirty thousand dollars
and that's the Illuminati anyway so
they're gonna keep the secret exactly
yeah hey Sona think of all the amazing
things in life that are expressions of
just you yeah I mean like the chocolate
that you had on your face when you came
in because you just ate that what was it
you were eating I was I was eating a
giant cookie giant cookie yeah and
that's so Sona okay or that song you
stream over and over again it's just so
you what's that song For You Twinkle
Twinkle Little Star yeah but it's for my
boys I know still it's nice okay or you
know that podcast that comedy podcast
you just gotta listen to yeah Conan
O'Brien needs a friend exactly is that
what you listen to in your spare time
yeah I love it everything that makes you
you makes all the difference State Farm
believes Insurance should work the same
way your plan your coverage selections
can be personalized by you and only you
that's cool I shouldn't shout but this
is how strongly I feel about it you go
to choose the plan you want by picking
the options that fit you like choosing
to bundle your home and auto policies is
what the State Farm personal price plan
is all about getting the coverage you
want at an affordable price just for you
call or go to statefarm.com today to
create your State Farm personal price
plan prices vary by state options
selected by customers availability and
eligibility may vary I think it's very
highly possible that it is like seven
different people who can look like
Taylor Swift they show pre-recorded
stuff on the big screens people don't
know it's playing to a track I heard TMZ
has footage of her backstage eating a
giant bowl of mushed corn
and uh just corn mash smoking a giant
cigar yeah a giant cigar and she on that
she's on the tape saying suckers
and she's eating it off of a giant table
that's made of uh million dollar bills
yeah that's that's a that's a tape that
I heard TMZ has but they're just slow to
get it out they've got some editing
problems
how they get their news out yeah can I
confess something yeah I can't name a
single Taylor Swift song
yeah today's the day here we go off on
our way so Conan cant either no I I'm
just naming them I'm ripping them off
they're they're incredible I'm just
they're rolling off my tongue keep going
who are you gonna be uh he was my
current but now he's my ex oh he's in my
rear view window don't need him no more
some of these actually sound like they
could do this and also a lot of her
songs are just like words that we use
regularly I love her song the acoustic
ballad you Jake Gyllenhaal oh
um she's got some great Tunes what are
you doing what's the matter you don't
like this segment I love it okay you're
getting all nervous and stuff I'm always
nervous what made it so standout like
was what what did you see at a Taylor
Swift concert you don't see elsewhere
the one I went to she announced 1989
Taylor's version and she's re-recording
that because someone else owns that
album yeah it's yeah it's weird I know
stuff about her but I couldn't tell you
a song
that's a whole idea I just had we'll get
to Taylor Swift in a second guys this is
okay so
we re-record every podcast word for word
and we sell them we sell them on
television late at night one on a 1-800
or a 555 number and it's called the
Conan the real Conan
1963 when I was born yeah and and we
sell them and we get to keep all that
cash yeah I'm in and then we disparage
these other ones because they're not
real they're owned by the man yeah what
do you guys think of that do you guys
want to do that because I don't know
I'm really really busy I don't have time
okay why don't you do hey David why
don't you do all parts excuse me
yeah including whatever interview we
have a wig here yeah uh so anyway keep
going so Taylor Swift oh no so she
announced 1989 so the whole night she
kept wearing like new blue dresses
because that's the color that represents
1989 why what is blue represent 1989 it
just culturally or by
all of her albums have a color
associated so David when the Democrats
are winning in a landslide that means
that that's Taylor Swift yeah that's
covering the map beating the red only
1989. I don't I just don't understand
why blue means Taylor Swift 1989. it's
just I don't know where it came from I
think the fans just made it into such a
major color you can't claim a whole
major color for one album she's not
saying no one else can use blue it's
just what represents it that's what I'm
saying hey 1989 was my blue phase and
then red I'm guessing was her red face
you know speaking out purple okay what
about midnights
black yeah no reputations black oh right
right who what's your favorite Taylor
Swift song
mine's long lives
that was good and what's your other one
All Too Well 10 minute version yeah 10
minute version yeah I think there's a 11
minute version I like because you just
hear her coughing and saying did we get
it
you think we got it where's my bowl of
corn yeah we got can I have my corn mush
now what else do you like I mean the
whole Midnight's album yeah don't even
get started yeah she's not the first
artist to have to re-record a full album
because she didn't own it no I know JoJo
did Def Leppard
didn't they lose the master recordings
that's why they re-recorded it I know
someone someone wouldn't allow them to
go digital with it and so they
re-recorded it note for note exactly the
same okay yeah well so you're why Reign
on Swifty's parade you're not raining
I'm just so are you like they were she
wasn't the first I think it's amazing
are you a leopard head yeah you are yeah
yeah because I'm cool right yeah Def
Leppard because I I know how to rock and
I like metal yeah okay pour some glucose
on me that's a white snake no no that's
the old deal oh it is DL what am I
thinking of I don't know what are you
thinking of you're so uh here I go again
it is the same song that's right all
rock songs are pretty much the same I
think Taylor Swift should record Def
Leppard songs and white snakes
yeah oh she should also record famous
news broadcasts yes no the Hindenburg is
coming into Lakehurst New Jersey and oh
my God the humanity the humanity how
about cheerful ones when does someone
break into the news and go him now
something cheerful a bluebird had a baby
oh no one does that it's always
something bad you don't know it guys
though the the War is Over yeah there
you go you did it oh we killed everyone
died
for nothing oh
no telling you all right I gotta wrap
this up David I'm glad you had a good
time and uh I am happy for all the
swifties out there my my daughter's a
huge Taylor Swift fan and she went to
the show and lost her mind and it made
her so happy that I was uh indebted I
was indebted to Taylor Swift seriously
I'm just it's it's nice to see someone
putting out so much positivity so yeah
yeah all joking no seriously all joking
aside I'm I'm I'm hugely uh happy for
her and just I think it's I don't know
we've had just so much bad news for such
a long time that when when people are
all excited about the Barbie movie or
Taylor Swift and Beyonce or Beyonce the
ladies are doing it ladies are doing it
Go Go ladies go because you seem to know
what you're doing we do not yeah all
right well I'm a lady well okay
[Music]
you're a broad
what a bride
yes you're a tough Broad
Sona was a bouncer for four years at a
clubhouse
I'd be nice people I'd have a lot of
regular because I'm cool too no I'm a
cool metal guy
can I end it now I haven't seen you at
the meetings because metal guys don't
say hey I'm a cool metal guy guys I'm
gonna be responsible we we had a better
ending and then we kept going yeah and
then when he said I'm a cool metal guy
there was just diarrhea on the wall so
I'm ending it peace out Tupac